why are some of these surgeries so
expensive because you see in the US it's
like quarter million dollars for a
surgery but then you'll see it done
overseas for 30 grand the number one
reason that I see it happening here is
because we don't have transparency in
pricing if you for example want to have
a cosmetic surgery you can call 10
cosmetic practices and say Hey I want to
get a nose job what's the cost of a nose
job and they will tell you their price
because they don't have to negotiate
with an insurance company but good luck
calling hospitals and saying hey I need
a an appendectomy which one is going to
give me the best rates they won't be
able to give you that because they have
different prices for one insurance they
have an agreement with this other
insurance and it's a disaster this is
largely driven by lobbyists who come in
and start lobbying the government to say
oh we need multiple insurance carriers
and as a result if you walk into my
practice and I tell you you need
treatment a I can't even tell you what
the cost of treatment day is because
it's so dependent on variables that are
outside of my control